the show opens up in a cafe where a
middle-aged man is nervously staring at
the clock on his phone as soon as it
hits 1 20 p.m he becomes anxious and
starts looking around nothing happens
for a few seconds but suddenly a loud
bang is heard across the city surprising
the citizens then three Supernatural
human-like creatures break into the cafe
they are continuously emitting black
smoke and their faces are scary as
everyone starts running in horror the
creatures approach the same man from
before and start throwing him around
like a ragdoll the man somehow manages
to escape and he runs to the main
Highway however the stubborn creatures
are not willing to give up so easily so
they chase him after an intense Pursuit
the monsters finally catch the man and
dish out a brutal punishment after he
becomes lifeless they lay him on the
road and perform a ritual which burns
him instantly now that the man is dead
and his soul has been extracted the
three creatures disappear Into Thin Air
monkey see monkey Sent send your ass to
hell yeah meanwhile we were introduced
to Jung jinsu the chairman of a
notorious cult group named the new truth
he regularly preaches his theories and
has gained quite a fan following one day
he claims that Sinister people are bound
to be punished by God and sent to hell
he also reveals that whenever a person
commits a sin an angel-like figure will
appear and tell them the exact time of
their death the scene then switches to a
police station where a laid-back
detective kyung-hoon arrives late at a
case briefing he notices that the entire
police department is talking about the
three creatures because the murder
happened in broad daylight many
witnesses have recorded the incident
kyung has taken aback to witness the
supernatural beings and after the
meeting is over he and his partner unpuo
are assigned to investigate the incident
wasting no time the two detectives
arrive at the crime scene and try to
find some evidence in particular they
look for Footprints but don't find any
they also can't find any traces of DNA
hence tired of all the dead ends kyung
decides to ask help from someone who
knows a great deal about the creatures
he is none other than the cult leader
Jung shortly after the two detectives
arrive at a gathering where Jung is
displaying images of people who were
killed by the supernatural monsters he
claims that whenever someone is supposed
to die an angel appears in front of them
and reveals their exact time of death
the only way to avoid their demise is by
living a peaceful life with no sins
involved after the meeting ends kyung
notices his daughter hee Jung there and
realizes that she is also a follower of
the cult group following this the
detectives try to interrogate young but
he only talks about his personal life he
reveals that when he was 20 years old he
wanted to commit the unthinkable but
fortunately when he saw the three
supernatural beings he changed his mind
instantly Jung believes that the
creatures have come to Earth to give
Justice to human beings so when he saw
the creatures for the first time he
formed the new truth group to make
people aware of the creatures however
kyung simply laughs at this and states
that the laws made by humans are
perfectly fine counter-attacking his
argument Jung reminds kyung how his wife
was murdered and how the Killer is still
moving freely to this day meanwhile we
are shown a single mother Park jungja
who returns home after a long day at
work to her surprise her children
welcome her with a birthday cake but as
the entire family is rejoicing at the
moment suddenly an angel-like figure
appears from nowhere and reveals that
Park will die in five days at 3 pm
Park's son who is ready to capture his
mother's reaction accidentally captures
the angel-like figure instead that
birthday cake better be delicious on the
other hand a popular live streamer is
shown he claims to be a member of
another faction group known as the
arrowhead surprisingly in this group all
the members are teenagers they do not
care about the law and always beat
people up who go against their beliefs
it is also revealed that the arrowheads
are inspired by the ideologies of the
new truth however John young asserts
that his group is not associated with
the arrowhead the following day the
woman from earlier Park meets up with
Jung and reveals everything about the
incident she also shows the video
evidence recorded by her son after
calculating everything a confident Park
gives her an offer she will be handed 3
billion won but in exchange her death
will be broadcast live on TV realizing
that her sons will be alone after she
dies Park agrees to the deal in the next
scene Jung arrives at Park's house with
a check for 3 billion by this time
several media Personnel have already
caught wind of this experiment after the
documents are signed Jung looks around
the house and curiously asks Park if she
committed a crime to get into this
situation however Park doesn't answer
and simply remains silent she is then
prepared for the live stream but her
identity will be kept secret fearing
that the religious freaks will attack
her the scene then shifts to the
arrowhead live streamer who is preaching
the ideologies of the new truth he also
discusses the three supernatural
creatures which have wreaked havoc
across City in the middle of the stream
someone anonymously talks about Park and
reveals that she is the one who will die
after five days to make matters worse
her address is also leaked later it is
revealed that the person who shared
Park's information with the arrowhead is
none other than un po all this time he
is an officer by day and a billed
Arrowhead follower by night at night
kyung returns home and searches for his
daughter when he fails to find her he
calls hijung and asks about her
whereabouts the latter lies to her
father saying I'm at my friends but to
everyone's surprise it is revealed that
she is actually at Jung's apartment
after Jung tells her that she can trust
him hee Jung starts narrating how her
mother was murdered one day when she was
little her mother sent her to deliver
clothes to her father the little girl
easily got distracted and so her mother
decided to go by herself unfortunately
on the way she was killed by a bunch of
bad people in the present hee Jung
mentions that ever since the incident
she has been unable to forgive herself
hearing all this Jung hugs her and
assures her that he and his group will
catch the murderer and provide Justice
meanwhile after learning that someone
has leaked Park's information on the
internet a lawyer named Hai Jin decides
to help she takes Park's children to
safety and sends them away to Canada
elsewhere Jung takes hee-jung to the
criminal who murdered her mother he then
provokes her to do something in order to
take revenge hijung does just that and
starts beating up the man in a fit of
rage she even finishes him off later the
two incinerate the bodies and pay their
respects surprisingly hee Jung who has
just killed someone starts smiling she
seems to be proud of what she just did
the next day the police find the remains
of the man in a charred condition
similar to what the supernatural
creatures have been doing this makes the
general people believe that whatever the
new truth group we're saying is true
together the arrowheads and the members
of the new truth gather outside Park's
house and to demand she confess her sins
before her death some of the arrowheads
also barge into the police station and
attack them demanding to release their
fellow members in the next scene the day
of Park's destined to death finally
arrives we get to know that the
demonstration is not only being
broadcast on the internet but also on
major TV channels a number of VIPs also
arrive at the place wearing masks to
hide their identity turns out that they
have paid a hefty price to watch the
demonstration up close soon Park is
brought on stage but she is too scared
to speak she simply waits for her
impending doom when the clock hits 3 P.M
nothing happens for a couple seconds but
suddenly a loud bang is heard and the
three Supernatural black creatures
emerge through the walls they quickly
attack Park and throw her against the
wall meanwhile kyung who is witnessing
everything decides to take matters into
his own hands he pulls out a gun and
hits one of the monsters with a few
shots however as expected it doesn't
affect them at all when kyung tries
getting closer to the creature it simply
punches him away after a while the
creatures finish off Park and incinerate
her they then leave the scene by jumping
and disappearing Into Thin Air because
of the strange occurrence all the
onlookers become terrified and bow down
in respect they start believing that
young was right after all the next
morning kyung wakes up in a hospital
completely healed from his injuries when
he gets out he learns that the entire
city has become empty as the residents
are too scared of committing a sin he
then goes to his office and turns on the
TV to watch Jung being interviewed by a
news channel during the interview Jung
reveals that the demonstration was just
God's message and that everyone should
return to their normal lives righteously
he says I plan to look for God's traces
until he calls me again meanwhile kyung
goes through the CCTV recording footage
and notices his daughter punishing her
mother's murderer at the same time he
takes a closer look at Jung's interview
where he notices his daughter's
sweatshirt because of this kyung
immediately leaves his office and heads
to find his daughter on the other hand
the arrowhead streamer is discussing the
previous day's funeral he reveals that
after after the creatures killed their
target and laughed most of the people
bowed down in respect however the lawyer
Hai Jin and her colleague didn't respond
at all the streamer conveys the secret
to anyone and soon people start noting
to kill the duo Hai Jin gets to know of
this and immediately departs for office
along with her ill mother sadly when she
reaches there leaving her mother in the
parking lot she notices that the office
has been vandalized by the members of
the arrowhead hygiene then tries to call
her colleague for help but gets to know
that he is an even worse condition
apparently the goons have beaten him up
badly realizing that she is the next
Target hygiene runs to the parking lot
only to find her mother being attacked
by the arrowheads after a while they
leave and hygiene immediately rushes her
mother to the hospital sadly it is too
late as she dies before getting any
treatment in the next scene kyung enters
Jung's apartment to find his missing
daughter he doesn't find anyone and
exits the building but just then some
angry goons start attacking him kyung is
almost beaten to a pulp but fortunately
Zhang calls him in the nick of time and
orders everyone to stand down he then
asks hyung to meet him at a nearby
school on the other hand a distraught
hygiene meets a reporter named Pastor
Kim who apparently interviewed Jung 20
years ago the latter is skeptical about
sharing his information but after a lot
of convincing he agrees Pastor Kim then
plays an audio recording which uncovers
a shocking truth apparently when Zhang
was just a kid the same Angel approached
him and revealed that he will die in
exactly 20 years the time will be 10 30
p.m hygiene finds the news very
informative and asks for the recording
however the pastor deletes it meanwhile
kyung arrives at the abandoned school
and finds Jung waiting for him without
wasting any time the latter reveals that
he was met by the angel 20 years ago
however the strange thing is that he
never committed a sin this implies that
the creatures do not target the people
who've committed since it is a random
selection so anyone can get killed even
a saint I don't know I'm sure he stole a
Pokemon card or something Jung further
explains that he formed the group the
new truth to spread his message that
Sinners should be punished in other
words he instilled fear into the minds
of people and now they have to think
twice before doing anything drastic as
the conversation goes on Jung threatens
kyung to keep his prophecy a secret or
else his group will expose his daughter
hijung's video in which she murdered a
man at last before the supernatural
creatures arrive and beat him to death
Jung tells kyung to enjoy his life to
the fullest he also says please take
care of my Remains the clock then ticks
10 30 pm and the supernatural black
monsters arrive there just like the
previous instances they throw him around
like a ragdoll and kill him and before
leaving they chant some prayers and
incinerate him as if nothing has
happened Monkey C Monkey blew your ass
up meanwhile hygiene is still with
Pastor Kim trying to find Clues on the
recent incidents she keeps asking him
for information but to no avail fed up
she decides to leave but Kim stops her
and reveals that Jung asked him to kill
her and take his position as chairman
hearing this an alarmed hygiene somehow
manages to escape but when she reaches
outside she finds the arrowheads waiting
for her they beat her to a pulp until
she stops moving in the last scene kyung
returns home and finds his daughter
waiting for him now he is faced with a
serious challenge as he has to keep his
daughter's secret hidden the episode
ends as we see hygiene's body lying dead
among the rocks under a bridge be sure
to watch series recapped for the
remainder of the show you're not going
to want to miss this story